the way I see it there are two kinds of
people in the world people who prefer
alien to the movie aliens and people who
prefer the movie aliens to alien that is
just how I view people secrets out
aliens that's right make it plural you
have a sequel are so Ridley Scott did
alien in 1979 about seven years after
alien James Cameron comes along he's
like you know what I want to make a
sequel I saw in the movie aliens
Sigourney Weaver plays Ripley again
she's been out in space she gets picked
up by the salvage team now she's trying
to get past the events of alien she has
this post-traumatic stress syndrome
going on she wakes up every night
freaking out because of the alien yeah
that thing it'll give you nightmares
it's just evil hey good news the whaling
company has colonized lv-426 which is
the planet where they found the alien
ship on and know they lost contact with
it I lost contact you know for a fact
that an alien has bust out of the chest
of every man woman and child on there
and now James Cameron's going to make
his move
how do we deal with that when James
Cameron does the sequel is very simple
you take Marines down to that planet and
you deal with the situation now we have
the movie aliens plural and this is what
I mean when I say it's a completely
different tone from alien it is it's an
action movie which is really funny
because ultimately a lot of the Marines
get wiped out pretty quickly four of
them get toasted because like these
grenades go off like boom all flatlined
for guys old that they're dead I mean
you got to give it up to Ripley on that
she has a better kill hit ratio than any
of the Marines do let's talk about
Ripley for a second Sigourney Weaver
completely owns the role of Ripley as
far as badass chicks go you really can't
think of a more badass chick in a movie
I mean really try yeah you thought of
Ripley didn't you so did I she was
actually nominated for an Oscar for the
movie aliens - I didn't know that until
just recently I always knew she kicked
ass in the movie aliens but I didn't
know the Academy was like really [ __ ] -
no one ate her food Oscar it's kind of
stuff that doesn't happen now and
although this movie has some kick-ass
action I mean aliens versus Marines
you're gonna have some kick-ass hurry
there yeah it doesn't go totally out of
left field and be like oh we're gonna
wipe our ass with everything that alien
was about and we're just doing our own
thing now there were some scenes that
were totally intense the scene where
Ripley is in that room with Newt and
there's a couple of facehuggers in there
I mean it's just intense as hell I like
that same I don't want that thing near
me seriously I don't like the fact that
they find that little girl Newt Newt
awesome because Newt
out you don't fight these things you
just run you run you hide you just stay
as far away from them as possible I
guess I'm kind of asked backwards in
that sense my first alien experience for
alien movies was aliens I was a little
kid I was flipping through channels and
there was a scene where the Queen was
right up against the great you know the
elevator great big old flamethrower
shooting at her my mom switched the
channel I was like what was that I was
like eight she was like that is a movie
you're not going to watch until you're
much older and I got much older and I
watched it and it was awesome I mean
that alien queen is one menacing bastard
and that's also another thing the movie
aliens does in the movie alien you don't
know anything about this alien it's just
that it's it's an alien you don't know
how it operates the movie aliens
establishes the fact they operate like a
hive you know like a beehive bunch of
drones and one queen that's really
calling the shots and this queen alien
and aliens is just it dude
it's enormous it's just it's big and as
far as sci-fi movies go aliens has one
of the most iconic throwdown just one on
one battles at the very end I can think
of hey Ripley versus the Queen alien
she's been that big mech thing I like
get away from her you [ __ ] you know
that line is just the best yeah unlike
scream two actually said it correctly
there that is what Marines vs. aliens
Ripley's a badass you have some creepy
ass moments you have a lot of excitement
aliens is one of my favorite action
movies it's just it's just all sorts of
kick-ass and aliens is awesome tacular
in a world of alien or aliens
I mean aliens guy myself I just am you
know that by now all right so are you an
alien person or an aliens person which
one do you prefer if you say alien
resurrection well artists subjective I
guess that's an acceptable answer kind
of whatever the case your favorite alien
movie comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
came over me